Flash, Flash, Flash.
You didn't think I was going to miss how this all turns out.
Tonight, we change the future
last chance to surrender, flash
We're going to slaughter your team, and end your legacy forever
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my flash finale video that's right the very last
episode of The Flash and the end of the arrowverse
as you know so rip poor went out press F to pay
respects to the arrowverse also explain what's
happening now with the Flash movie and all the
big DC reboot stuff and now they're sort of
reorganizing the way they do DC TV shows like
the whole way James Gunn is rebooting the DC
Universe is to be a little bit more like the
way that Marvel does their stuff where they
have Marvel Studios TV shows on Disney plus
like big budget shows with the movie actors who
also cross back and forth between the TV shows
and the movies as opposed to the way the DC used
to do their TV shows completely separately from
the movies if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos I'm
also supposed to see The Flash movie next week
as soon as they let us I will post a review of
the movie but they only spent about half of
the final episode with the actual conflict
like the villains versus The Flash the second
half of the episode was basically wrapping up
all the character works and setting up what's
going to be happening in this future timeline
where they leave things like the new world title
of the episode this Last Arc the way that Grant
Gustin talks about it he said he's always game to
come back like Stephen Amell said the same thing
too they would love to come back and do like
a limited series or some HBO Max or now it's
just called Max some special they only come
back for a couple episodes okay okay let's go
all right let's go we'll see if they ever wind up
doing that I think it's a Never Say Never kind of
situation like John Wesley's ship probably never
expected to come back and play The Flash but he
did come back several times as several different
characters like he did during this episode there
were lots of cameos because it is the finale the
episode starts with the same opening narration
from the pilot episode he gives the exact same
speech you have to believe in the impossible
to understand what I'm about to tell
you you need to do something first
to understand what I'm about to tell you you
need to do something first they repeat it during
the episode a couple different times like Keon
references it and then he also says it at the
very end of the episode when he's talking to Nora
baby Nora just in general there were several lines
of dialogue during the finale that referenced
either earlier lines of dialogue or just moments
from across the history of the show like the
biggest moments with all the villains cobalt
blue was essentially the main villain of the
finale though even though it brought back all the
Flash's biggest villains from earlier points in
the timeline the whole idea is the negative speed
force wanted to create a new timeline where that
positive speed force where Barry never existed so
we could just grow unchecked so it brought back
all these different villains from across their
timeline right before the flash kill them which
is the twist that they used during Spider-Man no
way home it was very Spider-Man no way home kind
of situation where all the Sinister Six villains
were pulled right before they were killed battling
the flash it was the same thing with the Speedster
villains they were all joint from the timeline
right before they died in battle or were changed
or fundamentally trapped for All Time by The Flash
the negative speed force essentially resurrected
Eddie Thon from the end of season one like this
is the dead Eddie that died during season one and
turned him into the new reverse flash even though
they're calling him cobalt blue like he's the new
Avatar of the negative speed force so essentially
going forward in this new version of the timeline
he is like the replacement for the reverse flash
in the comics cobalt blue was Malcolm Thon he was
like this long-lost brother of Barry Allen in
the TV show world when the negative speed force
resurrected him he was going by the name Malcolm
in this future timeline the whole idea with the
cobalt blue storyline in the comics is that they
were like a line of the Thon family like the
reverse flash family across history that battled
The Flash family if you're a big anime fan it
was kind of like JoJo's Bizarre Adventure with the
Joe Stars battling Dio across their family history
Zoom comes back the Harrison Wells reverse flash
savitar godspeed and even though the negative
speed force doesn't really care about any of these
other villains it just uses them to try and fight
the flash to kill him that's the whole idea they
even referenced that during the episode like does
the negative speed force even care about you teddy
Sears Zoom is the first one to come back from the
end of season two right before he was turned
into the new black flash so he doesn't remember
anything that happened after the end of season two
Tony Todd also came back to do the voice of Zoom
when he was wearing the mask he also just did the
voice of the new Venom character in Spider-Man 2
which I just did a trailer video for so I'll post
links with that down in the description below
we there's also a rumored that Teddy Sears had
a cameo in The Flash movie like they had a CW TV
show Cameo during The Flash movie but it wasn't
Grant Gustin it was actually Teddy Sears playing
a version of Jay Garrick so it's all wonky like
wait a minute he was 100 Solomon why did cameos
Jay Garrick in The Flash movie I haven't seen
the movie yet I'm supposed to see it next week
so we'll see what winds up happening I'm sure
there will be lots of discussion about this
Grant Gustin claims he's not in The Flash movie
but he might be lying no yeah there's been a lot
of rumors out there for a long time and no one's
like come out directly and asked me like ever like
you know on the record godspeed gets joint from
right before team flash defeated him it was fun
to see the villains share scenes together like
they chewed all the scenery and they made fun
of each other like you would expect like a lot of
the dialogue in the episode is the writers also
making fun of themselves in previous seasons
of The Flash lick reverse flash making fun of
Zoom for being derivative copying his move of
pretending to be team Flash's Ally because that
was one of the complaints after season two in real
life but the fans are like wait a minute this is
just like the season one story he also calls him
a velocity nine junkie because that was basically
the season two storyline then doing the velocity
nine from the comics Tobin Bell also came back
as the voice of savitar most of you will remember
him as jigsaw from the Saw movies they also wind
up changing savitar's color from Blue to Red
after the negative speed Force brings them back
empowering them because the negative speed force
is red when reverse flash makes fun of Eddie Thon
calling him the dumbest branch on his family
tree that's just another reference to the way
the cobalt blue storyline plays out in the comics
across the entire family line of the thawns they
briefly reference Eddie thon's familial connection
with eobarathon during season one too just briefly
they used a lot of the same twists from previous
Seasons callbacks to previous episodes like bigger
episodes like stealing more speed force energy
when Jay Garrett comes back saying that he
learned the trick quote unquote from his friend on
Earth 90 which is also a reference to John Wesley
ship playing the Barry Allen from the 90s Flash
TV show coming back during crisis on infinite
Earths so it's basically John Wesley ship saying
he learned a trick from himself they also had a
new Flash logo at the beginning highlighted with
a cobalt blue energy for this Last Arc of the show
the whole thing with the title a new world like
I said is meant to be a reference to the Last
Arc In general the reference to the timeline the
villains are trying to create create a completely
new timeline where they survive and cobalt blue
basically replaces The Flash as the only Speedster
on the planet because he also kind of plans to
get rid of the villains too it's also a reference
at the end of the episode where the flash creates
this new world this new timeline where he doesn't
disappear like the future newspaper said so he
creates another new timeline again which he's done
many times on the show they're also using that
twist during The Flash movie but in a slightly
different way like they're doing a version of
Flashpoint but it's a very different amalgam
version of Flashpoint there were a bunch of other
cameos Stephen Amell did not come back but they do
reference Oliver Queen at the end of the episode
referencing his speech during the pilot episode
saying that the lightning chose Berry when Barry
says he's going to choose the other new speedsters
they didn't have any more Flash movie crossover
scenes or references like Ezra Miller didn't have
any kind of Cameo scenes or anything like that and
they didn't reference Grant Gustin being in The
Flash movie and Cisco also did not come back John
Wesley's ship obviously came back as a version of
Jay Garrick Michelle Harrison who also plays
Barry's mother and a bunch of other characters
came back again as his wife Joan Garrick from
that Earth they brought back the speed force
lightsabers that was a big twist in previous
Seasons Nora comes back from the future and they
also reference the events of season 3 with savitar
impaling Iris when he tries to kill Nora Chester
Runk almost gets killed by a reverse flash and the
process becomes the chunk version of his character
from the comics like his whole name Chester Runk
is Chunk in the comics but when they debuted him
on the show they just called him Chester he
got black hole power so they're just saying
that now he's more like the comic book version of
his character the whole reason he doesn't wind up
killing cobalt blue at the end of the episode is
to save Eddie thon's life because he's basically
been perverted by the negative speed force he
winds up forming a truce with the negative speed
force which leaves Eddie Thon as the new Avatar
kind of like the new reverse flash like I said
even though he'll always go by the cobalt blue
name when they say they'll have disagreements in
the future that just means that they'll continue
finding each other in the future like they'll
continue having Adventures after this last episode
and essentially it's all done by about halfway
through the episode like they form their truce
and they go their separate ways Nora is born and
then they basically wrap up all the rest of the
character arcs the original Harrison Wells who
had not become reverse flash comes back because he
turned into a cosmic version of his character and
then kind of departed in previous Seasons he tells
kyoncinis to ascend so if you're not familiar with
what's going on with killer frost they changed
her character so many times over the seasons
if you checked out she died fighting a version of
Death Storm when she was resurrected she basically
became a God the god part of her had to ascend
leaving behind the human form of Caitlyn snow
so she's kind of like the season one version
of Caitlyn snow but she has all the memories
from the past couple of Seasons Joe S winds up
proposing to Cecile because even though they had a
baby together and they've been living together for
years they never actually got married Nora's crib
her baby onesie also decorated with her comic book
excess symbols her eyes flashing with speed force
energy is just to remind you that she will become
a Speedster in the future and he explains that his
whole reason for creating the new speedsters
at the end of the episode is to help protect
Nora essentially so that he doesn't have to spend
his entire time protecting the rest of the world
there are other speedsters that they can rely on
he goes back to the same Airfield from Ferris air
Big Green Lantern reference from the pilot episode
they went back there a couple times throughout
different seasons and essentially empowers three
new speedsters from the comics so they do Max
Mercury finally doing the character on the show
there's been so many theories about his character
for so long like they had Mercury Labs going
back to season one but we never actually saw Max
Mercury this is Avery ho who in the comics became
the flash of China this is Jess Chambers who also
became the flash of a different Earth and did just
travel the Multiverse but on the show they're just
explaining that all these characters come from
Central City and they'll work with Team flash at
the collider and that's basically it and this is
what Grant Gustin has said about the ending that
sort of coincides with my theory from many many
years ago when I thought about it ending there
was a theory out there that Barry would sacrifice
himself to keep the speed force alive and become
the lightning bolt that inevitably struck him and
create this full circle moment which I thought
was really cool and I always kind of wanted
him to die a hero's death in a way and I Eric
um was very opposed to the idea what my original
theory was is that they should actually just do a
version of the comic book story it was a really
small story but it was essentially Barry Allen
becoming the bolt of lightning that gave him
powers in the first place so the whole idea
is that this was tied to crisis on infinite Earth
in the comics and Barry sacrifices himself during
that comic book storyline to stop the anti-monitor
and he seemingly dies but what really wound up
happening is that he traveled so quickly that he
turned into the bolts of lightning that originally
gave him Powers becoming the flash so the whole
idea in the TV show is that it would have been
really cool for them to bookend the series where
he basically creates a Time Loop where he becomes
the bolt of lightning that originally gave him
Powers so like the show season one to season 9
is a big loop it was cool to find out that Grant
Gustin also wanted that ending for a while but
the current flash showburner said that they
changed that they wanted to give him a happy
ending I think just because they wanted a happy
episode of TV for a serious finale I don't know
if that's better you can decide like you watch
and you decide whether or not you wanted the
more hardcore ending or the happier ending as
for The Flash movie we'll see whether or not
Grant Gustin is lying about actually having a
cameo in it because it would really suck if he
didn't have a cameo like if we're ending the
flash wouldn't it be cool to see him pay off
that moment from crisis on infant Earth's with
some real quick kind of Cameo seen in the speed
force my review of that will post as soon as they
let us do that I'm not sure when the embargoes up
for that all the new DC tv shows will be big
budget Max series kind of like Peacemaker the
work like the Disney plus Marvel series the next
one that's going to Premiere is going to be the
Batman HBO series based on Robert Pattinson's
Batman with the penguin character I will do
episode videos for all that stuff whatever they
wind up releasing whatever shows I will do videos
for it so don't worry about that I did a trailer
video for that just a little while ago so I'll
link that Below in the description too over the
many years I had a ton of fun doing videos about
the arrowverse and I will say one of the most fun
things that ever happened to me doing videos for
the arrowverse stuff is that really early on when
I first started making videos Stephen Amell was
like one of the first people whoever actually
said anything nice about my videos which is
really cool of him that was almost like 10 years
ago that's how long it's been there's a bunch of
really big stuff coming up so I'll try to make
videos for everything everyone click here for
all my brand new Flash trailer videos and click
here for my brand new Blue Beetle trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!